let's head back to Edinburgh we're
expecting a fly past any minute now by
the Red Arrows after King Charles that
received the Scottish crown jewels
during the service of dedication in the
city's Cathedral are all correspondent
Laura bundock is in Edinburgh alongside
the former Garrison sergeant major at
Edinburgh Castle warrant officer class
one Anthony Gibson Laura of course the
fly past on the day of the coronation
back in May was uh disrupted wasn't it
because of the the weather it was uh cut
back somewhat
um how are things looking today judging
by that beautiful shot of Edinburgh the
weather weather's looking uh pretty good
much better in fact if it was this time
yesterday I can tell you that some
flights weren't even allowed to land at
Edinburgh airport because the cloud
cover was so low but today the sky is
much clearer a beautiful afternoon in
Edinburgh in fact as we await the
arrival of the Red Arrows you're right
the red arrow is simply couldn't take
part and we saw the resumption of what
was meant to be the big fly part in the
coronation taking place that trooping
the color a couple of weekends ago but I
think the the looking up at the sky
there's no reason why they won't be
taking part today and of course quite a
finale isn't it Anthony to what's been
this enormous day of sort of military
organization and display yes um more
spreads ending with the Royal Air Force
and the Red Arrows uh flying over
um really puts the icing on the cake to
any type of parade so everyone will be
looking forward to the skies and
watching for that red white and blue
flying over the top and it really will
be as I said the icing on the kit
days and days they've been having really
late rehearsals in sort of specially
built gyms and the like to get all this
in the Precision is there a sense that
they not
steal their Thunder if you like but
they're not just the icing on the cake
they're sort of detracting perhaps some
huge amount of preparation everyone else
has to put in I think it's just the end
of that military spectacle I don't think
it is lost on everybody about the amount
of work that goes in there might be that
jovial banter between the the forces but
that's always going to be the case um
I'd love to see that that Sky painted
red white and blue as well so and we
know now that the king will be in the
gardens here the weather favorable
enough for him to be outside to watch it
as well and given his background he will
appreciate and he knows that the effort
that has gone into all of today yes more
certainly he will be 100 happy with what
he's seen from his Armed Forces on
parade and he'll be really grateful for
the effort that has been put in it won't
be lost on him it will have been
communicated exactly how many days
preparation these soldiers have been
doing and that will be communicated to
him through 51 Brigade who are in in
command here in Scotland and the various
senior Chiefs of the services here in
Scotland
involved what have we seen what have we
witnessed today
so all up there's about 350 Personnel on
Parade
um with regards to the amount of horses
who you've seen close to
125 horses or so from the household
Cavalry and the blues and Royals and
they've come from London and they have
come from the south yes or one unit from
hounsel and the other from from
Knightsbridge
um so they've dedicated a lot of
personal time having to arrange the
horses are actually in temporary
stapling within Redford Barracks here in
Edinburgh and there's a lot of work and
a lot of people in the background
facilitating those movements and they
are the unsung heroes of those parades
as well and despite
there was a very distinctive Scottish
feel to it all today that the Pipers
some of the some of the troops we've
seen taking part too most definitely
um this is Edinburgh this is Scotland
and to have The Kilted Soldier on parade
is an absolute must those supporting
armed forces that ironing kills are you
know equally as Scottish but the Kilts
and the bagpipes and the Highland attire
of the various units out there do really
steal the shore and as it should be
it was the extent I mean you organize
not just today but you were very very
closely involved at the organization the
Queen's funerals thirdly the Scottish
aspect of it all
do you feel a sense of completion now
yes the the full circle has come about
um
from my arrival during the pandemic to
receive a Magister for the first time
and then obviously the the sadder case
of her her passing while she was here
and and the situation where the soldiers
that were predominantly involved in all
of those parades are getting to see his
Majors as the King on Parade for the
first time receiving the honors of
Scotland and it is really a case of a
fresh start with the Monarch and the
Armed Forces here in Scotland
involved the King has been
with what's taken place
so not too long ago about a month ago
the Lord lion Dr Joseph Morrow QC went
down to London where he fielded this
plan written by 51 Brigade and he
overall gave the thumbs up to say let's
go let's do it and there has been a few
changes along the way in that time since
that acknowledgment what changes what
have we seen what did the king want the
chase today it's not so much what the
what the king wanted James it's it's
little things the inclusion of the youth
pipe band for instance within Edinburgh
Castle escort in the honors from Crown
Square through and over the drawbridge
on Edinburgh Castle Esplanade
um
the ergonomics of what the visual would
look like in regards to the tattoo
stands in place at Edinburgh Castle
didn't give us the full Visual and we
only got to see action from uh Castle
Hill down to West Parliament Square so
little things like that made the Army's
preparation police Scotland's
preparation slightly more harder in
regards to affecting things like the
transporting and how to close the roots
Etc so minimal impact basically to the
city as best possible
planning involving the two protest pens
as well so that was part and parcel
you can just see the king there coming
out I'm assuming making his way out
because the planes will be arriving soon
as well
just briefly on those protests
presumably that was taken into account
as well yeah most definitely it was one
of the things that uh Scott government
mentioned when we were in Communications
with them and all the various teams
meetings that took place it was
something that everyone was conscious
that had to take place and you know
freedom of speech is there for everybody
and yeah
and then we can see there that you can
Duchess of Rossi as William and Kate and
own
in Scotland as the plains approach
well Spectators are treated to a red
arrows display going over the Royal mile
past the Palace of Hollywood house and
Edinburgh Castle just look at that
[Music]
circuits
it's very quick lore isn't it
doesn't last long
but it certainly has an impact
we were talking about that being the
icing on the cake Anthony it is the
icing on the cake and that is ultimately
the signal for all troops on Parade to
now one give the final Royal salute to
his majesty and the Royal harnesses on
parade and then they'll leave parade
foreign
[Music]
there we go Little Wave from the King
there
a little way that probably says a lot
this has been a big day for him and a
huge day in the planning as well and as
I think as he slips back inside the
palace a big sigh of relief Anthony from
everyone who's helped make the day yes
most definitely within headquarters now
they'll be happy to see his majesty step
in into the Palace of holyrood and
there'll be multiple conversations about
returning all of the troops and horses
and anybody else on Parade via the
different concentration areas that
they'll go to so Edinburgh Castle and
Johnson terrorist here at the broad
pavement on holyrood and it will be
about returning everybody all kitten
equipment safely back to Redford
barracks and for the individuals right
down to their personal experience how
will they be feeling right now
really proud
um if if I could be on that parade I
know I'd be immensely proud of whichever
part I took uh part in whether I'll be
at West Parliament square or here at the
palace I would be chuffed to them but I
would be seriously impressed Anthony
Gibson the former Garrison sergeant
major in Scotland he helped organize
today thank you very much back to you
Laura thank you very much the
formalities uh over as we look at the
the heart of Edinburgh there King
Charles having received the honors of
Scotland those those crown jewels in a
service of Thanksgiving pageantry and
prayer taking place in Edinburgh
following on from the coronation in May
let's take a look at some of those other
news now